these golf balls a science fiction set  an alien invasion nope  this is Bava gun and the only  inhabitants here are humans located in  the Netherlands about an hour away from  Amsterdam a 50s fear houses made from  cement and reinforced with fiberglass  bolívar again which actually translates  to ball or bulb Holmes was built in 1984  by the Dutch artist and sculptor Therese  creche cam it was created and supported  by a subsidy from the Dutch government  for experimental housing projects inside  the houses at three levels bedrooms on  the ground bathroom on the middle and a  living space on the top although these  homes look out of this world  their intention was to bring its  inhabitants closer to nature the round  windows allow the use of the outside  environment from almost any angle and  the complex itself is positioned near a  scenic canal the designer passed away in  2014 however his legacy lives on as  these homes are still lived in today  [Music]